[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation en
association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec François chemet
directeur de la Mission Locale Skyway 16
25 Léa ourliers et Yohan villetard vous
êtes tous les deux des jeunes suivis par
la Mission Locale bonjour à tous les
trois bonjour à François
objectifs de la mission locale au
quotidien des objectifs de la mission
locale c'est d'accompagner les jeunes
dans leur démarche d'insertion sociale
et professionnelle pour cela ils auront
toujours un conseiller référent et qui
les accompagnera parce qu'il peut y
avoir des périodes où ils ont plus
besoin de la Mission Locale parce qu'ils
ont trouvé puis après ils vont revenir
ça c'est le marché de l'emploi qui qui
fait ça certains jeunes viendront une
fois trouveront la réponse à leurs
questions ou éventuellement on la trouve
on ressentiment eux qui n'en l'ont pas
trouvé ça peut aussi arriver voilà
d'autres jeunes seront suivis de 16 à 25
ans qui sont nos limites belges on vous
accompagnez donc les jeunes du
territoire vers l'accès à l'emploi et à
la formation l'émission ne date pas
d'hier et pourtant le covid a mis un
coup de frein l'accès à l'emploi pour de
nombreux jeunes est-ce que vous estimez
que la demande est plus importante
depuis cette période
alors le covid avait eu un fort impact
sur les jeunes en effet on avait
beaucoup vu beaucoup de jeunes perdre
leur emploi à ce moment-là j'avais eu
aussi un impact sur l'accueil par la
Mission Locale parce qu'il était étant
fermé le télé que faire de l'accueil que
en télétravail c'était très très
compliqué
après la sortie du covid il y a eu deux
mouvements un retour des jeunes vers la
mission locale et aussi en même temps
une embellie du marché de l'emploi ce
qui fait que beaucoup de jeunes ont à ce
moment-là trouver des emplois et on n'a
jamais eu des taux d'emploi aussi fort
que en 2021
et alors justement 50 ans en Yvelines
typiquement c'est cet territoire où il y
a environ 17000 entreprises donc c'est
finalement un territoire aussi qui est
force de proposition en termes de
formation et d'emplois tout à fait oui
il est la mission locale et les jeunes
ont la chance
qui réside sur Saint-Quentin ou une
chance assez exceptionnelle c'est à dire
qu'il y a plus d'emplois que de
population active ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il n'y a pas de chômage ça veut pas
dire que les emplois soient adaptés aux
compétences de chacun mais enfin c'est
plus facile ici que sur d'autres
territoires pour moi l'outil vous les
accompagnez également dans certaines
démarches sociales comme l'accès au
logement ou à la santé les jeunes
aujourd'hui ne sont pas assez informés
sur les aides auxquelles ils ont droit
[Musique]
qui sont environ 100 000 par an à
quitter les bancs de l'école sans
qualification mais ce n'est pas tout ce
n'est pas seulement les jeunes en
situation de décrochage scolaire c'est
aussi les jeunes qui sont sortis du
système scolaire donc même avec un avec
un bac avec avec un diplôme etc oui
initialement l'émission locale ont été
créées pour les jeunes de très bas
niveau de qualification mais au fil du
temps le public a changé et on accueille
tout jeune et aujourd'hui plus la moitié
des jeunes qu'on accueille ont un niveau
bac ou plus obtenu alors Léa et Yoann
vous avez justement pris connaissance de
de ce dispositif et vous y avez même
adhéré Johan on va commencer par vous
comment est-ce que vous avez connu
justement ce dispositif classe départ
j'ai connu le je n'ai pas fait j'ai pas
fait la case départ vous c'était le
c'était le truc donc on va on va plus on
va plus rester sur les ah pardon donc
Léa comment est-ce que vous avez pris
connaissance de la classe des femmes
grâce à la Mission locale grâce à mon
conseiller donc parce que j'aimais bien
tout ce qui était art
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce que ça vous
a apporté justement ce dispositif
notamment au niveau des arts à travers
les heures ça m'a aidé à reprendre
confiance en moi
avant c'est aussi pour
plus que je voulais faire aussi et me
pousser à aller faire des études à
reprendre les études tout ça alors
aujourd'hui quel est votre votre projet
professionnel justement bah là j'ai
repris un DAEU option littéraire donc
c'est un équivalent du bac
pour ensuite faire des études en droit
et pour faire une année en généalogie
et moi typiquement les arts c'est pas
c'est pas ce qui m'attire déjà de base
mais il y a dans les arrières il y a de
la culture et c'est justement un domaine
qui se perd moi je trouve
personnellement donc on compte sur vous
pour le refaire vivre Yoann vous du coup
vous allez participer au système trek
alors qu'est-ce que le système trek
c'est l'organisation
lors de d'une série de saint-cyrion d'un
d'un projet de voyage
point de de Treg d'une randonnée sur
séjour on fait 25 km par jour et pendant
ces 25 km il faut
on a différents sentiers principalement
des sentiers de randonnée assez
complexe et
enfin assez complexe il y a de tout type
de sentiers mais c'est faut les tenir
sur 25 km et ça nous fait ça nous forge
un mental pour persévérer pour aller
jusqu'au bout ben justement vous êtes
partis en italien c'est ça pour le
dernier truc
on a marché sur la vias 36 Gena de
Vercelli dans le Piémont jusque jusqu'à
Aoste et qu'est-ce que vous retenez
justement quels sont les objectifs à
travers à travers ce trade est-ce que
c'est simplement de faire des randonnées
où est-ce qu'il y a des objectifs
derrière l'objectif principal c'est une
forme de persévérance il faut persévérer
pour se dire il faut il faut aller au
bout il faut pas abandonner
dès lors qu'on commence à avoir un un
peu mal aux pieds ou un peu mal au dos
il faut aller au bout il faut continuer
il faut il faut se dire que bah si
j'arrive à faire ça peut-être que
j'arriverai à faire d'autres choses plus
importantes et plus importantes
professionnellement parlant donc ça aide
finalement à aussi mettre en avant
certaines compétences et surtout à ne
jamais baisser les bras alors justement
baisser les bras c'est c'est ce que
certains jeunes font quand ils ont
l'impression de ne pas avoir assez
d'aide ou de ne pas avoir de ne pas être
assez écouté votre rôle c'est aussi ça
c'est de leur montrer qu'il ne faut pas
baisser les bras et qu'il y a toujours
une solution oui bah la recherche
d'emploi c'est quand même un parcours du
combattant et il est tout à fait
intendable que des jeunes aussi
d'ailleurs les moins jeunes à un moment
baisse les bras parce que quand on se
prend plusieurs échecs répétés répétés
répétés ben on y croit plus tellement il
y en a pas envie de de recommencer donc
le rôle du conseiller c'est aussi
lorsqu'il a plus de nouvelles d'un jeune
d'aller vers et d'essayer de le
remobiliser si pense qu'il en a besoin
il y a également le parcours jeune donc
vous avez connu tous les deux un petit
peu le parcours jeune donc c'était
sortir organisé deux trois fois par mois
quels sont les objectifs en tout cas
pour vous de de suivre ce parcours
parcours culture pardon
ça permet de découvrir des choses que
[Musique]
j'annonce ce serait dit
quoi tout ça on passe à côté on fait pas
forcément attention et là ça permet de
voir des enfin
comment dire de des spectacles peut-être
que vous avez peut-être pas l'habitude
d'aller voir où
de voir différents horizons et pas
rester dans son coin
[Musique]
justement donc vous vous voulez vous
porter plus sur la culture ou la
médiation culturelle qu'elle est plus
précisément votre projet quels sont vos
projets pour l'avenir alors je j'aime
beaucoup la culture j'ai vraiment envie
de partager mon intérêt pour la culture
au plus grand nombre et je trouve que
justement de nos jours il y a une grande
il y a certains jeunes qui n'ont pas
forcément trop d'accès à la culture et
se disent que ah c'est peut-être ça
c'est peut-être pas forcément pour moi
et au final
la mission locale et là pour
pour le pour les emmener pour vers la
culture vers le vers le vers certains
spectacle qui effectivement il n'aurait
jamais eu l'occasion d'aller s'il y
avait pas assez dispositif là et vous
typiquement justement vous avez un
diplôme vous avez suivi une licence
effectivement une naissance de l'or ça
c'est important moi je pense de le
souligner on a toujours l'impression que
l'émission locale ça va être justement
des jeunes qui sont en décrochage ou qui
ont juste le bac etc non la mission
locale c'est justement de 16 à 25 ans et
pour tous les profils tout à fait tous
les profils moi j'ai trouvé ça
intéressant de le mettre est-ce que pour
finir on pourrait peut-être donner un
conseil aux jeunes qui n'osent pas
toujours se tourner vers la mission
locale notamment sur ces stéréotypes qui
qui colle à la Mission Locale quel est
le meilleur conseil qu'on peut donner à
ces jeunes qui n'osent pas spécialement
se tourner vers la mission locale
Johan peut-être
toutes les aides sont bonnes à prendre
il y a plein de structures qui peuvent
aider aider les jeunes et notamment
l'émission locale il y en a un
appartement
en France et on l'a vu à travers votre
votre témoignage que la mission locale
peut justement aider sur tout type de
domaine même du coup artistique et
culturel on vous souhaite du coup de
poursuivre vos projets professionnels
merci beaucoup à tous les trois d'avoir
répondu à nos questions pour plus
d'informations on peut se rendre sur le
site Skywest 25.fr et pour revoir ou
réécouter cette émission rendez-vous sur
notre site et notre application radio
sensation
[Musique]